look you guys all know my feelings about
thomas jefferson i talk about him often
he is my favorite founder if you have
not seen it a couple years ago we did a
president's week series of episodes
where i did a full hour uh on thomas
jefferson uh he lived an extraordinary
life he was writing the documents that
were freeing the slaves in the midst of
writing the documents that were freeing
us
from britain i mean he was he did so
many things and he was an inventor and
extraordinary extraordinary person i've
been to his his home down in monticello
in uh in virginia a couple times i
highly recommend you go there and they
give a fantastic tour there uh well
surprise surprise the woke cultists now
want him taken down wherever he might be
and they are succeeding in places such
as the new york city council we've got
some info from the new york post here
thomas jefferson is no longer in the
room where it happens art handlers
packed up an 884
pound statue of jefferson in a wooden
crate monday after a mayoral commission
voted to banish the likeness of the
nation's third president from new york
city hall where it resided for nearly
two centuries because he owns slaves the
1833
statue will be on long-term loan to the
new york historical society which plans
to have jefferson's model survive in its
lobby and reading room carrie butler the
executive director of the public design
commission that voted to banish the
statue at first tried to block the press
from witnessing its removal butler
relented after members of the mayor's
office and city council
intervened and we've actually got some
video of the statue being removed after
187 years
all right so almost 200 years that thing
was there 187 to be specific
do you feel the tolerance do you feel
we're becoming less racist do you feel
we're becoming more diverse and more
open and more thoughtful as a society as
we burn down our history do you sense
that or could this be about something
else could this be about destroying all
of the good past of the united states so
that they can usher in their woke crypto
fascist marxist lunacy do you think
maybe that's closer to what it's about
i've often talked about the the
conflicting history of thomas jefferson
who was just a man of his time much like
we are all just men of our time right
like i love eating a steak is it likely
or possible that in 30 years from now
they will look back on us with our
instagrams of those beautiful juicy
tomahawks that i
smoke and go my god he was evil and then
they're gonna have to take down the
giant bust of me wherever it might be
where do you think they would put a bust
of me
somewhere back in the back of my office
will they take down my office yes um
we are all men of our time we're all
imperfect we in most cases try to do the
best we can and we often fail at that
thomas jefferson as i said he was
writing the laws to free the slaves he
was conflicted about slavery he felt
that it couldn't just you couldn't just
rip the band-aid off he wasn't a pure
abolitionist in that way but he was he
was trying to make it happen he we know
he had relations with at least one of
his slaves like these are all very
complex things you can also go to george
washington's home in dc and you they
talk about during the tour they talk
about how when when washington died
that he freed his half of his slaves in
his will but martha kept hers does that
mean we should
take down every washington statue i mean
i don't want to give these people any
ideas um but
the idea that these people were somehow
racist and backwards and now 200 plus
years later we're just so great and
we're just closing the loophole on all
their evil crap so that we can be good
and tolerant and diverse going forward
it's just
it's a bill of goods that they're
selling you that is that is
faulty
it is broken and there will be no
warranty on it once we say goodbye to
our history there will be no getting it
back they will usher in something that
will be far
far worse if you thought that george
washington and thomas jefferson were bad
guys wait till you are under the rule of
ilhan omar and aoc and all of their
friends and you will find out the true
meaning of racism and intolerance
because it wasn't those guys it really
wasn't